thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode hey crazies there's this
super uniform microwave static coming
from all directions seriously all
directions
it's the cosmic microwave background the
CMB tune your radio telescope to the
right frequency range and you get static
no matter which way you point it here
static there static everywhere static
which you know is kind of weird but what
is it where did it come from and frankly
why should we care
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon so we
noticed pretty quickly that the static
wasn't all the same frequency as you
turn the frequency knob the signal
gradually gets louder hits a peak and
then gets quieter again we can even
figure out the intensity of each of
those frequencies and plot it on a graph
when we do that we get something that
looks like this it's a thermal spectrum
what's a thermal spectrum it's light
emitted because of temperature so you've
got a rock sitting on a table the reason
you can see it is because light is
reflecting off of it but let's say you
painted it with the blackest paint you
could find now we'd call it a black body
which is just an object that's black
when cold it might not be able to
reflect light anymore but it would still
be emitting light in infrared just
because it's at room temperature that
light is made by the molecules inside
the rock if we make the rock really hot
though we can get it to emit visible
light the thermal spectrum which is peak
in a different place we could even
figure out the temperature based on
where the peak is as it turns out the
CMB is also a thermal spectrum it just
Peaks in the microwave range instead of
the visible range based on where it
Peaks we know whatever is emitting this
light is about 2.7 Kelvin and let me
tell you this spectrum is as close to
perfection as you can get
just to give you an idea of how perfect
this is the sun's thermal spectrum
compared to the ideal curve based on its
temperature it might be close enough to
call the Sun a blackbody but it's not
perfect
doing the same comparison for the CMB
gives us this look how beautifully it
matches hmm good stuff it's as close to
a perfect thermal spectrum as you're
gonna get which leads to an obvious
question what the heck is emitting this
thing could space itself be emitting it
I mean space is pretty black seriously
check this out
I can color this paper with a sharpie
and it seems pretty black right now look
what happens when I poke a hole in it
and put a dark void behind it see how
much blacker that dark void is space is
the blackest black but hold up if this
black void started emitting light we
have to assume there was some kind of
matter inside it
after all the temperature is atomic
jiggles and you can't have atomic
jiggles without atoms hmm
let's see for something that cold it's a
pretty strong signal like seriously
2.7 Kelvin just a few degrees above
absolute zero
that's cold plus it's coming from every
direction what could possibly be
everywhere wait a minute
microwaves are just the type of light
and the speed of light is finite if this
thing's coming from far enough away it
could be coming from the distant past to
the timeline no no not when it was
discovered when it was made if you want
to learn about the discovery of the CMB
you can check out physics girls video
it's a good one you might even recognize
a name or two in the end credits but no
I mean the cosmic timeline we're talking
billions of years ago before there were
humans before the earth formed before
the first stars in the galaxy lit up
before there were even atoms in the
universe space was filled with plasma
that's not the stuff in my blood right
no you you definitely don't want this
kind of plasma in your blood plasma is a
soup of charged particles it's way too
hot for neutral
to exist but say you and one of my
clones are floating around in it with
invincibility powers you'd both see a
pale orange light coming from every
direction not from everywhere in the
universe though during the plasma years
the universe was about 80 million light
years across but you could only see a
few thousand light years in any
direction
that's only one ten thousandth of the
way across the universe see light
doesn't get very far in a plasma it
keeps bumping into charges like protons
and electrons it was like a very violent
pinball game the light was constantly
being created and destroyed that light
was far more likely to be coming from
nearby if my clone were to drift away
from you he gradually be obscured by a
fog of particles that all changes when
neutral atoms happen the universe was
continuously expanding and cooling off
when it got to an age of about 380,000
years old it dropped below a temperature
of 3000 Kelvin that plasma that was
filling the universe stopped being a
plasma electrons and protons came
together to form neutral hydrogen with
the charges gone light was free to move
through the universe unobstructed the
universe became transparent we called
that period in cosmic history
recombination because names are dumb
sometimes the light emitted during that
time is the same light we're receiving
as the CMB that static we get from all
directions was created during
recombination when the universe was only
about 380,000 years old
at the time the temperature was 3000
Kelvin so the distribution peaked in the
near infrared there was quite a bit of
visible light in there hence all the
orange you'd see if you were around back
then but a long time has passed the
universe is much bigger and much cooler
now it peaks in the microwave range that
corresponds to a temperature of 2.7
Kelvin it's still a thermal spectrum
just a much colder one but remember how
I said the spectrum was as close to
perfect as you can get well close to
perfect
not the same as perfect there are some
tiny temperature variations the CMB has
spots the blue spots are slightly colder
and the orange spots are slightly hotter
of course this is the universe so those
spots are enormous today there are about
550 million light years across
like I said enormous but when those
spots were made the universe was 1,100
times smaller they were only about half
a million light years across at the
moment of recombination and those spots
were made with sound waves the density
of that primordial plasma wasn't
perfectly uniform the slightly more
dense parts collapsed under gravity and
then rebounded in a shock wave that
travelled over half the speed of light
that's how we know how big they are
before recombination when everything was
a plasma matter and light were coupled
remember the pinball game light didn't
get very far without interacting with
matter so any changes in the structure
of matter were accompanied by the same
changes in the pattern of light but
during recombination everything changed
light became decoupled from matter and
the pattern of light was frozen that
pattern is what we see in the Cosmic
Microwave Background this is a map of
the structure of the universe when it
was only 380,000 years old and that map
tells us a ton about the universe like a
crap time stuff that lets us model the
entire timeline of cosmic history of
course the CMB is not the only place we
get that information it's important to
collect corroborating data from multiple
sources like patterns in the location of
galaxies this structure matches the CMB
that simulation was created by a
supercomputer called Mira I got to see
it in person a couple years ago it was a
great experience there's a blog if
you're interested anyway modeling is
important because we can only see as far
back as the CMB it's the oldest light in
the universe any physical record of the
universe before that was destroyed
almost immediately
all we have for that era are the models
and data we collect from particle
accelerators so what's the CMB it's the
Cosmic Microwave Background it's cosmic
because it fills the observable universe
probably the entire universe to its
microwave because it peaks in the
microwave range of the electromagnetic
spectrum and it's a background because
it's a very uniform signal coming from
all directions the CMB is a thermal
spectrum leftover from when the universe
was only 380,000 years old the CMB is an
afterglow from the Big Bang it's a
record of the distant past
so got any questions about the Cosmic
Microwave Background please ask in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy if you want to learn more
about cosmology brilliant is a good
place to start
their astronomy course begins by
teaching you the tools scientists use to
study the universe it ultimately ends
with several cosmology quizzes one of
which is on the cosmic microwave
background astronomy is just one of over
60 interactive courses and math science
and computer science that brilliant has
to offer try adding some learning
structure to your day by setting a goal
to improve yourself and then work at
that goal just a little bit every day
brilliant makes that possible with
interactive explorations and a mobile
app that you can take with you wherever
you go
if this sounds like a service you'd like
to use go to brilliant org slash science
asylum today the first 200 subscribers
will get 20% off an annual subscription
[Music]
if gravity is a gradient in time how can
gravity affect photons they don't
perceive time right right photons don't
personally experience time but they're
not taking the measurements we are in an
our reference frame they are traveling
through space and time anyway thanks for
watching